[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele menschen glauben dass der kauf von
dingen auf anni express das gleiche
bedeutet als würde man sein geld direkt
der kommunistischen partei chinas
schenken
und wenn man so einige medienberichte
liest bekommt man den eindruck das ist
eine direkte beziehungen zwischen
zwischen bingen und chinesischen
unternehmen gibt richtig nur das ist
nicht der fall
aufgepasst
[Musik]
china stoppt den 37 milliarden dollar
börsengang derart grob oder berufung auf
große probleme falls jetzt ist die art
group ist eines das
dienstleistungsunternehmen das teil der
alibaba gruppe ist und ja ali baba ist
auch die muttergesellschaft von
aliexpress wir sprechen hier von einem
der größten und bekanntesten unternehmen
in ganz china
es ist nicht nur ein
technologieunternehmen das hand in hand
mit den großen gedanken deswegen rallye
konkurriert es ist auch eines jener
chinesischen unternehmen das im ausland
die größten marktanteile gewinnen konnte
doch die chinesischen behörden legen den
börsengang der antrieb allerlei steinen
[Musik]
es gab sogar gerüchte über das
angebliche verschwinden des gründers
jack ma er verschwand für mehrere monate
aus der öffentlichkeit nachdem er in
shanghai eine höchst umstrittene rede
gehalten hatte
in dieser rede kritisierte er die
chinesischen banken und
aufsichtsbehörden scharf doch keine
sorge
jack ma ist inzwischen wieder
aufgetaucht und wohlauf trotzdem hält
die chinesische regierung den börsengang
seines unternehmens and fun and noch
immer zurück die fragen die sich nun
also stellen sind was ist chinas problem
mit seinem größten tech unternehmen
warum macht die chinesische regierung
eine so große sache daraus dass and
financial an die börse geht sollte sich
die kommunistische partei nicht um ihre
unternehmer kümmern damit diese die welt
erobern können
heute werden sie diese fragen
beantworten aber zuerst wollen wir einen
blick in die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
finanzinstitute sind nicht mehr die
ewigen sieger in den letzten 25 jahren
hat die chinesische wirtschaft ihre
größe um genau das 25-fache vervielfacht
ein absolut spektakuläre wachstums
rekord
[Musik]
und natürlich kann man angesichts dieser
daten sogar die grundlegendste tatsache
vergessen egal wie viele wolkenkratzer
neonlichter und 5d antennen sie haben
china ist immer noch ein kommunistisches
land nun eher eine art hybrid der sogar
die fünfjahrespläne beibehalten hat und
wo die wichtigsten banken dem staat
gehören ja es stimmt es gibt private
banken aber sie sind sehr klein
mehr als die hälfte des chinesischen
finanzwesens in den händen der großen
staatsbanken in der realität bedeutet
dass fall eines die pata demokraten sind
diejenigen die lässt nicht entscheiden
wer einen kredit bekommen kann
die priorität dieser banken liegt nicht
daran kredite an haushalte oder kleine
unternehmen zu vergeben sondern an
staatsunternehmen
hinzu kommt dass die chinesischen bank
vorschriften viel strenger sind als die
in europa oder den vereinigten staaten
mit anderen worten wenn man ein kleines
unternehmen ist ist es fast unmöglich
eine bank dazu zu bringen einen um geld
zu leihen um sich eine vorstellung davon
zu geben
weniger als ein fünftel aller
chinesischen unternehmen werden von
banken mit kapital versorgt und zum
vergleich in ländern wie deutschland
oder spanien leipzig jedes dritte
unternehmen geld von banken und das
erklärt die kritik von jack ma die die
chinesischen banken so wehgetan
seht euch folgendes wir müssen die
pfandhaus mentalität des heutigen
finanzwesens ändern und auf die
entwicklung eines kredit basierten
systems setzen die heutigen banken haben
weiterhin eine pfandhaus mentalität
sicherheiten und garantien sind etwas
pfandhäuser so herrlich und ihr fragt
euch vielleicht wenn die banken kein
geld verleihen wie bekommen dann noch
einmal ich in diesen krieg wie können
sie in diesem land kleine unternehmen
gründen nun die antwort ist über kleine
geldverleiher die oft wucherzinsen
verlangen viele chinesen sind so durch
unbezahlbare schulden in den ruin
getrieben worden und so liegt es auch
die ganze zeit bis er in financial
auftauchte
erin financial ist ein globales
technologieunternehmen
es wurde auch alipay gegründet das in
china als treuhand service eingerichtet
wurde um vertraut zwischen online
käufern und verkäufern aufzugeben seit
der ersten transaktion hat sich alipay
zur weltweit größten digitalen
zahlungsplattform entwickelt und ich
weiß was ihr jetzt denkt mal sehen ob
ich das richtig verstanden habe er in
financial alipay digitale
zahlungsplattform 'nen das ist das alles
eine neue bank nun es ist ein
unternehmen dass du an ibarra gruppe
gehört aber ist allem aber nicht auf die
commerce spezialisiert was machen die
mit krediten um das zu beantworten
werden die uns das jetzt mal etwas
genauer anschauen
[Musik]
die us-bank alibaba wurde im jahr 1999
gegründet zunächst war es ein portal das
kleine chinesische hersteller mit
ausländischen unternehmen verband die
von ihnen groß und das produkte kaufen
wollten dann ging man dazu über an
endverbraucher zu verkaufen
zunächst auf den chinesischen markt mit
timo und tauber und schließlich in die
ganze welt mit allen extras heute
wickelt alibaba 60 prozent der
chinesischen e commerce ab und sie
dominieren fast ein drittel des globalen
ecommerce
[Musik]
alba war ist auf der ganzen welt für
ecommerce bekannt aber in china geht es
noch viel weiter im jahr 2004 starteten
sie eine eigene zahlungsplattform alipay
davon ausgehend gingen sie es über
weitere finanziers leistungen anzubieten
kredite an kleine und mittlere
unternehmen kredite an privatpersonen
und so weiter und so fort und so wurde
ein neues unternehmen innerhalb der
alibaba group geboren
er entfernt und genau hier beginnen die
probleme von alibaba denn der konzert
beginnt dienstleistungen anzubieten die
traditionell von banken angeboten wurden
früher waren banken die herren des
geldes heute nicht mehr
jetzt gibt es unternehmen die transfers
des giro und revolution phänomen das
sich in china europa und überall auf der
welt abspielt aber es gibt einige
bereiche in denen art revolutionär ist
eine davon ist ihre junge piraten öffnen
von alipay können nutzer auf der
startseite aus einer reihe von
geldmarktfonds zu wählen sie können ihre
einstellungen zu anpassen dass alle
gelder von ihrem konto abgehoben und
direkt in die überbau eingezahlt werden
ein neubau ist eine geldmarktfonds gut
was ist das nun gelten als ein wenig
bekannt dass wir das instrument die
funktionsweise ist die folgende du
liegst geld in yuan und dieses geld wird
investiert und kleine kredite an andere
leute zu vergeben wo erhält einen
höheren zinssatz als wenn du dein geld
als reguläres festgeld anlegt außerdem
kannst du es wieder abheben immer du
willst und hier kommt das super vorteil
es gibt dabei keinen mindestbetrag
technisch gesehen kannst du nur eine die
man investieren was umgerechnet etwa 15
cent entspricht und dank dieser
eigenschaft ist dieser frau in china wie
eine echte bombe eingeschlagen
ach was wie eine atombombe
[Musik]
alibaba group wird zum größten geld
nationen der welt
urban verwaltet mittlerweile bis zu 270
milliarden dollar
mit anderen worten die an eine echte
finanzregelung gesorgt und das ist der
grund warum der börsengang des
unternehmens der größte in der
geschichte sein sollen ja das ist
richtig
es wurde erwartet dass die aktien dabei
für insgesamt 37 milliarden dollar an
anleger verkauft werden und zur
veranschaulichung den börsengang der iss
haben die arabischen ölgesellschaft
aramco brachte nur 29 milliarden dollar
doch monate vor dem börsengang
staatlichen aufsichtsbehörden auf die
bremse und warum eigentlich das werden
wir gleich herausfinden ideologische
gründe neben jubel bau hat und viele
andere möglichkeiten von find ich
erforscht vermögensverwaltung kmu
kredite und jede menge anderer arten von
dienstleistungen
dadurch gewannen ist einen gewaltigen
vorsprung gegenüber chinas bank studien
besagen dass finanztechnologie in
weniger als fünf jahren mehr als 40
prozent der potenziellen kartengebühren
in china aufgefressen haben werden was
ist für die banken einen jährlichen
verlust von rund 60 milliarden dollar
bedeutet aber es geht nicht nur um die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen viel
gravierender ist die politische
dimension welche diese veränderung mit
sich bringt der erdrutschartige
abwanderung der kunden von staatlichen
banken hin zu finden unternehmen wieder
angedeutet ist facto die privatisierung
des ganzen staatlich kontrollierten
bankwesens in china mit allen
konsequenzen welche dies die
kommunistische partei nach sich zieht
den verlust der kontrolle über die
chinesische wirtschaft denn wer das
bankwesen kontrolliert kontrolliert die
wirtschaft und deswegen fiel die
reaktion der chinesischen behörden
derart heftig aus
[Musik]
chinas präsident hu shaping hat jack ma
star persönlich vereitelt aber das ist
ein moment denn das ist nicht der
einzige grund wir sprechen nicht nur
über eine reine ideologie sondern auch
im hintergrund über ein politisches
machtspiel ungeahnten ausmaßes das ist
also gut auf
politische gründe
wer ist der größte nutznießer eines
erfolgreichen börsengangs nur diejenigen
die bereits vorher anteil des
unternehmens besaßen
mit anderen worten diejenigen die anfang
entsteht aktien besitzen erwarten dass
der aktienkurs steigt sobald sie an die
börse gehen
und der gehört zu den größten investoren
in diesen unternehmen und schauen wir
uns das mal etwas näher
investmentgesellschaften die mit dem
enkel des ehemaligen präsidenten jiang
zemin und dem schwiegersohn des
ehemaligen mitglied des ständigen
ausschusses des politbüros dirk engling
verbunden sind profitieren von den
börsen dank damit ihr den kontext steht
eine der ersten entscheidungen die sie
sind pink traf sobald der präsident von
china wurde war die partei von
korruption zu säubern
mit anderen worten alle seine
politischen feinde zu beseitigen so
konnte er schließlich die totale
kontrolle über die partei übernehmen nun
viele dieser ehemaligen parteikollegen
zumindest die die nicht bis zum
lebensende im gefängnis gelandet sind
oder hingerichtet wurden haben ihr glück
als unternehmer gesucht und wenn dieser
börsengang schafften würde würde sich
das nicht nur zu millionären und
milliardären machen sondern auch zu
eigentümer des größten finanzinstitute
des landes sie hätten quasi durch die
hintertür wieder ein stück kontrolle
über die chinesische wirtschaft kommt
das erklärt warum china erst im jahr
2020 solche maßnahmen ergriffen hat
peking gleitet kartellrechtliche
untersuchungen gegen ali baba 1
es ist schon merkwürdig dass man mit
diesen untersuchungen erst im jahr 2020
begangen denn vor sechs jahren konnte
man mit fug und recht behaupten dass
alibaba ein monopolist damals machte das
unternehmen 81 prozent des gesamten e
commerce umsatzes in china aus heute
dagegen ist ein marktanteil auch nur
noch 55 prozent gesunken aber wartet
einen moment wir wollen hier wirklich
fair sein denn wir reden hier nicht nur
über politik oder ideologie es gibt
tatsächlich einen wirtschaftlichen und
einen ganz legitimen grund dafür and
financial zu regulieren schauen wir uns
den mal kurz an
[Musik]
wirtschaftspolitische gründe
man könnte sagen dass einfach eine
kleine bank ist die kein geld hat sie
agieren nur als vermittler
man fragt bei 1 financial einen kredit
an und wird mit kleinen kreditgebern
oder direkt mit banken verbunden und ein
paar menschen ist das gesetz nicht
verpflichtet wo zwei prozent eines jeden
krieg selbst zu finanzieren
daher kommt hier ist die große frage was
passiert wenn die schulden nicht
zurückgezahlt werden das problem läge
dann nicht beim vermittler sondern beim
tatsächlichen kreditgeber mit anderen
worten ein special hat wenig eigenen
anreiz sache zu sorgen dass eine kundin
zahlungsfähig sind
im gegenteil
ihr ziel ist so viele kredite wie geht
raus zu holen als gäbe es kein morgen
und die sich ja schon worauf das ganze
eigentlich hinausläuft so manche
erinnern sich vielleicht noch ein
bisschen an dieses namens kreditblase
mit uns krise
[Musik]
und tatsächlich auch hier könnte eine
blase entstehen die das freie
hypothekenkrise sehr ähnlich ist mit
anderen worten and financial ist
möglicherweise bereit ihm geld zu leihen
der nicht wirklich kreditwürdig ist dann
kann es gute schulden und schlechte
schulden in paketen bündeln
diese pakete werden dann an brücken und
investoren weiterverkauft und um genau
diesen teufelskreis zu verhindern hat
die chinesische regierung folgende
maßnahmen vorgeschlagen
china verschärft die regeln für die
online kreditvergabe ein neuer schlag
für jack ma sant group kurz gesagt was
die regierungsbehörden von paid
fondation verlangen ist dass das
unternehmen 30 prozent seines geld ist
dass es verleiht aus der eigenen tasche
aufbringen
auf diese weise hat das unternehmen eine
stärkere motivation sicherzustellen dass
alles eine kundin kreditwürdig sind und
ja 30 prozent ist eine wirklich hohe
zahl
so vergleicht banken in der eurozone
müssen nur eine reserve von einem
prozent vorhalten mit anderen worten mit
diesen neuen vorschriften wird ein
financial gezwungen sein
bei der kreditvergabe viel konservativer
zu werden fast so konservativ wie die
traditionellen chinesischen banken
natürlich können solche maßnahmen
durchaus eine finanzkrise die von 2008
verhindern aber auf der anderen seite
verhindern sie auch dass sich tausende
von kleinunternehmern geld leihen können
um ihr wachstum zu finanzieren
[Musik]
die frage ist nun also glaubt er dass
china eine gute entscheidung getroffen
hat wenn ich ihr das hier das tritt auf
die bremse bei allianz tochter
wirtschaftlich motiviert ist oder ist
ist nur eine strategie der
kommunistischen partei chinas um ihre
kontrolle über die wirtschaft zu
behalten
wie immer sind wir auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat was er geht
uns mit einem leicht teilt es mit euren
freunden und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren macht und ist
[Musik]